you said you signed up for a plural
marriage yeah and that's something that
you want yeah
can you see yourself
asking him like let's try this again
I can I'm scared of it because
of how badly this has gone Robin Brown
admits how she really feels about her
life with Cody now that his
relationships with Christine Janelle and
Mary are over there's so many people out
there that are getting like a different
view of what our plural family is
because of because of our show so it's a
big deal to me on TLC's Sister Wives
one-on-one finale Robin gets emotional
talking about the life she envisioned
with Cody's former wives it's not the
future I wanted
I want that house
with us on the porch
the rocking chairs or their grandkids
and our kids around us you know the
grandparent Ranch
that's what I want
and I don't know how to let it go yeah
there's been big changes for the Brown
family in the last year like Christine
leaving Cody so for us plural marriage
doesn't work
for us marriage to something I just like
me and I like my life so much better now
Mary and Cody also called it quits he
says no I don't consider myself married
to Mary
like he just made the decision and he
and Janelle officially separated Cody
and I have separated and I'm happy
really happy which leaves Cody with one
wife Robin the only one he's legally
married to and when it comes to him
adding another wife he's made it clear
in the past he's not open to it there
will never be a fifth wife but now that
he's down to one that could change Robin
wants to live in polygamy but has her
fears about bringing in new women I'm
scared of it because
of how badly this has gone
I really really struggle with it because
it feels like you know oh well those
didn't work so on to new
you know that's that's hard for me yeah
that's really really hard for me it
feels disrespectful yeah and monogamy
Robin has mixed emotions about it could
you could you see yourself living a
monogamous life with Cody
I think this way I've really really
struggled with it I don't know what to
do with it it's messing with my identity
I think the biggest thing for me is that
that people understand that we chose
this we're not broken
um that you know our biggest and most
important thing is the love in our
family and even though we have issues in
our family we are always working towards
working it out and becoming stronger as
a family however that looks but Cody
doesn't think polygamy works for him
anymore I'm right on the verge of not
even being a polygamist and that's been
part of my identity for 30 years what's
funny to me now is I was always a
forward-thinking guy I was always
thinking about the future and how great
it's going to be and how good it is
right now but it's great these days I'm
thinking about well it's good today but
I really miss the past too I for the
first time in my life I'm really looking
back a lot
and missing some of the past and
regretting a bunch of it
[Music]